it's been quite a while since bleach
ended yet I'd say its legacy still lives
on now I don't know about you but I have
to say the zanpakuto are among the most
striking elements in Bleach magical
swords gifted with unique powers I'd say
that the concept of the zanpakuto is one
of the things that made bleach the
success that it was
with this long anime and various
spin-off novels bleach has a lot to look
back on it may have fallen off a lot
compared to its glory days but it
remained an exciting read for fans even
as it ended to the point where many
people still clamor for the return of
the anime only to get a live-action
movie that no one really wanted it was
even set to have a major announcement
before the ill-fated timing of the
worldwide virus epidemic cancelled
numerous events in Japan including the
one with an upcoming bleach announcement
turns out that that announcement was
heaven for the fans in addition to
getting an animated adaptation of burn
the witch the next arc of the main
series the thousand-year blood war arc
is going to be adapted into an anime
after almost a decade bleach is set to
get an anime again rumors are that it
would be airing in 2021 and that's a
really long time away one year is just
too long for some people which is why I
instead take solace in playing video
games featuring our favorite Nogami
enter the sponsor of this video
bleach immortal soul bleach immortal
souls an officially licensed game that's
being created under approval from the
anime team behind the Bleach anime you
know what that entails voice acting
fresh from the anime so you can hear
once again the trademark lines that
you've grown to know and love if you're
someone who needs a review of the anime
bleach immortal souls got you covered
collect and level up your favorite
characters and lead them into battle as
you relive some of the classic moments
in the anime battles are fun and
strategic with deep emphasis on not just
gotcha luck and character strength but
also order of attack and team
composition whether you'd breeze through
the game or play it tough like Ichigo
would it's entirely up to you check out
the link in the description to play
Bleach immortal souls for free so for
today we'll be taking a look at some of
the coolest sign factors in my opinion
no hard criteria for this and I'm gonna
just rank them according to how
interesting or impactful their dynamics
are in the series now without further
ado let's get started in our countdown
of the top 10 zanpakuto in Bleach take
note that the majority of the list is
going to be taking note of a
abilities and performance is seen in the
manga so spoilers are ahead if you're
one of those eagerly awaiting of the
anime returning starting off the list we
have no sera she right off the bat we
have a spoiler zanpakuto on the list
what is na surah she you may ask why
it's our favorite blood Knight and
battle sage Kenpachi Zaraki zanpakuto
yes in the final our camp archie finally
released his zanpakuto and the lead ship
saw that we have all grown to love gives
away to a great axe giving our already
destructive captain even more raw power
in true Kenpachi fashion Asura she
retains its wielders brute-force gimmick
allowing him even more destructive
capabilities but that's not even getting
to its bank I form yet in bank I no sir
ah she pretty much turns Kenpachi into
bleach his version of faith stay Knights
Berserker just look at that appearance
and judge for yourself
Kenpachi is nigh unstoppable in this
form and he pretty much becomes a
demonic Herald of decimation in bank I
few zanpakuto can match no sir ah she in
terms of raw power but in a world of
creative ability such as bleach raw
power ain't gonna cut it
further up the list we move on to
something more familiar to those who
have grown up on the anime zabi Maru
who could forget Renji signature
whipsawed that turns into a bony snake
zabi Maru has been a mainstay in Bleach
and it came with an awesome debut
episode during the soul society ugh
unfortunately it's Bank high form has
since been power creeped and overall
even with this supposedly powerful bank
ID Renji doesn't have the best win-loss
record out there despite everything zabi
Maru is still simple and pretty cool too
much like a lot of the main characters
aren't active zabi Maru gets a much
needed upgrade in the final arc in the
form of its true bank I form now known
as so savvy Maru renji's true bank eye
rests upon its wielders body in a much
cooler form
it also gives Renji nifty new attacks as
well such as an ability that allows
Renji to fire spiritual blast through
energy generated jaws coming up next is
another zanpakuto that you'd have
actually seen and grown familiar with
already thanks to the anime actually
more people know for its bank I form
rather than his shikai form with how
often it gets used in bank I I'm talking
about here in Maru
[Music]
the site of hitsugaya and his ice dragon
wings has been a fan girl dream since
the peak years of bleach die gore and
here in maru needs no introduction and I
think few zanpakuto has the distinction
of giving its wielder such an iconic
change in form in terms of ice powers
not combat hitsugaya and Corrine Maru
known as the strongest ice zanpakuto
during Maru grants hitsugaya tons of
flower themed ice abilities that
specialize mostly in direct offense
putting him in contrast with the series
other prominent ice wielder who
specializes in area of effect combat
more on that later
hitsugaya proves that training does pay
off and in the final arc of the manga he
unlocked dagger and cure in Mario's
complete bank I form transforming him
into its ago huyn maru makes it
therefore the shaikh cultural impact of
its form I don't think that there is a
zanpakuto transformation that's more
recognizable than tiger ensuring Maru
among the bleach fandom
on the topic of bank I releases we have
the zanpakuto with the honor of the
longest gap between ash acai and Bank I
reveal this is aura Hadas Benner he made
it didn't take long for us to see Benner
he may shock I used by or ihara in the
early arcs Benning he made functions
similarly to Zang ketsu
in the sense that it fires beams it can
also be used defensively due to its
ability to manifest a red shield however
the most intriguing part about Benner he
may comes in aura Hadas comment about
its Bank high form not being fit to
trade others why is that so you might be
asking after 600 chapters in the manga
we finally get our answer it's not a
bank I primarily built for combat or
training in place of the usual physical
or magical attacks that bank I typically
get Benny he maze bank i form
specializes in reconstruction befitting
a genius creator like johanna the bank
is able to reconstruct anything at the
molecular level so that means dissecting
and stitching O'Hara's injuries together
and altering the enemies properties the
best part about it its effect isn't
limited to combatants even the
environment can become O'Hara's weapon
should he decide to reconstruct pathways
with his bank I by Kai
[Music]
now at first glance ashisogi jizo seems
to be a zanpakuto fitting for resident
mad-scientist Mayuri to put it lightly
it looks disgusting and off-putting a
true reflection of its own a sick and
twisted personality in the anime my URIs
used a she surely Jesus Sakai form as a
poison injector more often however
Mayuri uses his zanpakuto in his bank i
form a gigantic caterpillar bound to
elicit some big-time nightmares yes
why if I tell you that it's not even its
final form Ashley shogi Jesus final bank
i form as seen in the manga takes the
form of an even more grotesque baby that
spits out clones of itself tailor-made
to counter whatever overpowered
abilities my URIs opponents use on the
flight my URIs Bank I can create a
version of itself to acts as a hard
counter counter Mayuri to create a bank
i that's the personification of his
ability to counter everything given the
chance and time to do so
[Music]
but is surely cycling tour nothing
Bujji
one of the more awaited Bank eyes in the
series is none other than the captain
commanders as such ryujin jakka blazes
its way to claiming the fifth spot on
the list those manga readers who were
curious as to what destructive
capabilities captain yamamoto held
didn't need to wait too long after the
conclusion of the fullbring iraq
powering his way through Quincy's in his
desperate bid to save soul society
captain commander Yamamoto unleashes his
ryujin jakka full potential with its
bank I've Zanka no tachi the bank I
creates a blazing atmosphere upon
casting causing far-reaching effects
akin to a drought for most people in
addition to the expected fiery powers it
also grants yamamoto a protective armor
of flames and the ability to reanimate
the dead pretty much nothing can stand
in the way of its sheer might Zanka no
tachi final move serves to incinerate
and burn everything in its way to a
crisp
rounding out our pre top three list is
byakuya
senbonzakura at 4th place I don't know
about you but I think that the image of
byakuya using senbonzakura is one of the
most visually stunning attacks in Bleach
breaking down into numerous cherry
petals that swirl around and slice up
his enemies
senbonzakura has been a fan favorite of
many owing mostly to its unique Flair
and the popularity of its wielder
if swarming enemies isn't enough
senbonzakura is bank iform can also be
converted into numerous forms of byakuya
such as a haul of swords and a sphere of
death it even got a new mode in the
final arc where he throws all sanke
swords in one go focusing purely on
offense with senbonzakura death by a
thousand cuts never looked so cool
before
the couch keys really have it down pat
when it comes to kicking ass while
looking as graceful as possible
following her brother's footsteps
Rukia proudly takes her place as the
owner of the number three zanpakuto on
the list fans of the anime would be
familiar with Sauron on Shirayuki for
its core and graceful modes known as
dances the first one creates an ice
pillar around Rukia while the second one
allows her to fire off a freezing wave
the third dance which allows her to
manifest a blade of ice out of thin air
looks tame in comparison things get even
more awesome in her manga only bank I
form named haka no togami
sword a no Shirayuki z' bank i form
releases a super AOE freezing field
causing everything around rookie to
freeze and subsequently crumble physical
contact with Rukia at this point would
even cause others to freeze due to how
cold she really becomes rookie as Bank I
appearance making her look like a queen
of ice is just the finishing touch she
truly takes after her brother when it's
all said and done
probably surprising a lot of you guys
now but the second-place zanpakuto for
me is shin so shin so is a simple
zanpakuto at Ginn's command it extends
pretty simple and compared to all those
colorful powers it may not see much
however it's true merit is in its bank
ID it's Bank life form as revealed in
the anime has the ability to plant a
part of itself into its target causing
the target to suffer sell you their
destruction at Ginn's beck and call it
seems unassuming and melts down an enemy
from within something that seems to fit
such a sly and venomous personality like
kin it takes a lot to elicit a legit
reaction of panic out of god mode Aizen
but again did this with his bank eyes
ability all that bullshitting to Ichigo
about its speed worked and for once the
mastermind via them finally got
outsmarted albeit temporarily seriously
I don't know way out of this we know
bleach can just bypass fatalities and
strong moves by throwing the reiatsu
explanation at us but a Spall's and god
modes aside i don't think that anyone
can survive shin Soze bank i ability
at the top of this list is an
often-overlooked zanpakuto due to the
level of exposure in the anime there's
just so little that the anime had a
chance to give for our captain kyoraku
and his twin swords zanpakuto gotta
think you're caught soon but someone
with his status as a senior captain he
gets so little focus and is somewhat
relegated to comic relief with only
serious battles featuring either his
unreleased zanpakuto or the Shiki which
you might remember to revolve around
games
well his bank eye as shown in the manga
takes a much more dramatic term instead
of forcing the opponent to play a game
along with him shouldn't sue he forces
his opponents to take part in what seems
to be a gruesome reenactment of a play
taking on a grim and heavy atmosphere
yaku's bank I accident phases that show
symbolism regarding his relationship
with nanaue and the Issei family but
I'll stop right there in order not to
spoil it any further in classic fashion
the banker ends with a simple clean
execution the delivery the overall drama
and the revelations during the bank i's
debut remains one of the standout parts
of the final Bleach arc in my opinion
and that's it honorable mentions go to
some more fan favorites notably zangetsu
suckin a day and kyoka suigetsu however
given the even in the manga we didn't
see much of those zanpakuto's new powers
most notably given the joke about ichigo
only knowing how to throw getsuga tensho
variations sadly sticking around and
holding true I decided that those
zanpakuto narrowly missed the cup
perhaps the anime will add some scenes
and give those swords more shine
especially given Politis tendency to run
filler arcs and episodes if this video
isn't enough to satisfy your craving for
more bleach anime and manga then I have
the next best thing for you bleach
immortal soul is now available to be
downloaded for ios and android and it's
the closest you're gonna get to
experiencing the magic of bleach once
again an exciting game that's bound to
offer more and more content possibly
even reaching the manga arcs beyond what
the anime aired
soul society is once again right at your
fingertips all you need to do is
download bleach immortal soul and return
to soul society once again battle it out
with your favorite characters level them
up and go through tough bosses and make
sure to take part in the various events
that the game has to offer for those
interested in playing the mobile game
you may redeem the code in the
description below for an amazing kick
off price well that's it for this
edition of the lists hope you enjoyed
this video don't forget to like and
share this
if you enjoyed it for now we anticipate
the return of the anime 2021 can't come
soon enough until next time
[Music]
[Music]